it's school choice week but what a
school choice mean how we spell the Sun
that's outside it might mean schools
were kids like learning learning is work
these kids or rather their parents chose
a different kind of school a charter
school that's a public school but one
outside the normal government
bureaucracy kids at these Success
Academy charters do remarkably well we
are number one in student achievement in
the state of New York we're
outperforming all of the wealthy suburbs
success Academy teaches mostly poor kids
but 95% passed the state math test 84%
the English test government-run schools
have a much lower pass rate how does
success do it you keep them in school
longer our instructional day starts at
7:45 middle schoolers go till 4:30
open up your book you should be sitting
up straight this is too hard on the kids
stressful China and India are not
worrying about the length of the school
day we have to toughen up a little bit
reading is work but it's rock and
awesome I think I'm ready cheer I've
read a hundred books our level of rigor
is much higher than in most district
schools just a few your rigor works it
does kids rise to your level of
expectation good morning kindergarten
scholars
and even though the kids work hard
somehow they like the work school is
boring they told me learning is fun how
is it fun to learn they just teach us in
a fun way I was surprised that the kids
seemed happy how could kids like work
it's hard it's hard but actually kids
like I'm succeeding at things so you
guys look forward to going to school in
the morning yes yet Eva Moskowitz is
hated when she goes to public meetings
to propose opening a new school people
scream at her they just hate you they
they do they do they hate her she says
because what we prove is that there's
nothing wrong with the children there is
something wrong with the system a
monopolistic system that is not allowing
kids to succeed time for Eva Moskowitz
to stop having the run of the place
defenders of the government monopoly are
everywhere
one is commentator no Mickey Constance
reality as charter schools are better
funded by these hedge funders and
they're performing worse than the
underfunded schools the results are in
it's a scam she's just wrong wrong about
the results but what about the funding
you have more money you've got
billionaires less money so New York
spends about almost $20,000 per student
yeah and I only get 14 five and I'm
getting vastly better results you do
well because you're a test prep factory
you just drill them we do not run
schools for tests we really believe in
games in kindergarten we play blocka
sand backgammon second grade we do
monopoly we have math teams robotics
teams debate teams you cherry-pick the
kids simply not true we admit by random
lottery many charters do you see
it's a random selection you all have
your numbers right
finally critics say yes Eva takes kids
by lottery but then she kicks problem
kids out you say maybe the school isn't
for you well why would our student
retention rates be so much higher than
the district are they they are
significantly we lose about 10 percent
of our families every year and the
districts lose about 20 percent all
reasons parents line up hoping to give
their kids a chance to escape
government-run schools this line goes on
and on kids whose names are not drawn
cry oh it's it's heartbreaking if you
win our lottery you are guaranteed as a
young child to learn how to read of
course not every charter is good some
turn out to be worse than schools they
replace but the beauty of choice a
market is that bad schools gradually
disappear the good schools grow Kipp
started a knowledge is power program
school just 20 years ago now the chain
has 209 schools
idea has several of the top-ranked high
schools in the country with 61 schools
it's now the fastest-growing charter
chain and Eva Moskowitz now runs 46
schools there's work to do on behalf of
children and I'm going to continue to do
that work
he was the Democrat who once believed
that government-run schools were fine
she explains that at her new book what
do you mean the education of Eva were
you dumb before well no I was not I was
not dumb but I I was blinded I think by
a belief that big government was a good
thing why didn't they but they need
freedom now Eva's been educated and her
students have discussions like this
everybody has a different life salt they
could do whatever they want
you